anyway this is the first time that my
son has ever seen me perform it's the
absolute honour of my life baby to have
you here tonight adele shouts out a
special someone in her audience so what
is the dream you hold for him
just to be a good person be a good and
happy person the heartwarming tribute
was featured in the adele one night only
prime time special on cbs
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
whether it was on stage in the audience
or above la landmark griffith
observatory there were stars everywhere
you looked but alongside celebs like
lizzo and melissa mccarthy was adele's
nine-year-old son angelo this is the
first time that my son has ever seen me
perform
and i got really um and he dressed up
for me it was a i'm not gonna cry
anyways too it's too soon to cry and i
don't want anyone to come fix me face
but um it's the absolute honour of my
life baby to have you here tonight
and you look so beautiful and so
handsome and smart
following the big night adele took to
twitter and said the concert had her
quote filling a million things at once
she then admitted quote it was also the
first time my son saw me perform and
i've never been so nervous in my life
so this whole album is dedicated to him
yes yep and in between performances
moments from adele and oprah winfrey's
sit-down interview where the grammy
winner opens up about the special
meaning behind her new album 30. i just
wanted for him to hear me
talking
mad madly deeply about who i am and how
i feel like you know and i don't know if
i'd ever be able to have that
conversation with him in real life adele
goes on to share the one thing she hopes
for angelo's future so what is the dream
you hold for him
just to be a good person
be a good and happy person
i don't expect anything of him
i don't
care what his career is as long as he's
passionate about whatever it is that he
does and he's happy adele and simon
connecky
father separated in 2019 after eight
years together but less than one year of
marriage their divorce was finalized in
march but adele says she only has love
for her ex
why do you think
is the real reason simon came into your
life
i think simon probably saved my life to
be honest with you he came at such a
moment
whereas
the stability that him and angelo have
given me you know even now i trust him
with my life really oh my gosh like
beyond like yeah i feel like
yeah him and angelo like they were
angels sent to me that's how i feel
how did she sound i believe nobody has a
voice like hers nobody
nobody and she did not disappoint
oprah's bestie gail king was also among
the star-studded audience and she gushed
to et about the singer leading up to the
concert all i can say is we all know the
song easy on me or we already know that
she played three new songs and then she
played her
you can't even call them oldies but
goodies she played some of her classics
but she just looked so good
the dress she was wearing made me think
i'm gonna give up eating cupcakes until
the next day